[Musique]
avec vos lames phrase bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline à la une de la presse
d'abord la victoire en australie du
parti travailliste aux législatives
après neuf ans de gouvernement
conservateur albanese réussi titre ce
matin les australiennes avec une photo
d'anthony albanese y promenant son chien
au lendemain de sa victoire le chef du
les bords a prêté serment ce matin pour
être le nouveau premier ministre toto le
toutou du nouveau chef du gouvernement
australien à la une également pauline du
sydney morning herald qui estime qu
anthony albanese y va devoir maintenant
trouver un équilibre entre la réalité et
la myriade d'attentes qui se sont
exprimées lors de ces élections en
matière de transition écologique de
pouvoir d'achat et de parité voilà
l'heure n'est pas à faire des blagues à
toto hélène la presse internationale
fait état de nombreux défis qui
attendent le nouveau gouvernement
australien lote financial times qui
précise que le comptage des votes est
toujours en cours 1 et qui n'est pas
établi pour le moment si les travail
sont en mesure de gouverner seul ou non
le quotidien britannique donc prévient
qu'il sera difficile pour ce nouveau
gouvernement de tenir ses engagements
notamment sur la croissance et les
salaires en raison de la forte hausse de
l'inflation et des taux d'intérêt dont
l'augmentation est d'ailleurs saper la
crédibilité économique du précédent
premier ministre scott morrison dont les
électeurs auraient rejeté la proche qui
a fait de l'australie à roda
retardataires mondial en matière de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre selon
le new york times qui demandent jusqu'où
ira le nouveau gouvernement en la
matière en australie comme aux états
unis il sera difficile de mettre fin ou
de modifier des habitudes énergétiques
vieille de plusieurs décennies commente
le quotidien en rappelant qu anthony
albanese i s'est présenté comme un
candidat du en même temps de la
transition écologique en s'engageant à
soutenir les nouvelles mines de charbon
et les énergies renouvelables
au risque de s'aliéner les verts qui
sont également en forte progression
voilà qui nous fait penser à quelqu'un
ici en france c'est jour de rentrée pour
le nouveau gouvernement celui
d'elisabeth bornes qui se réunit
aujourd'hui pour son premier conseil des
ministres les échos dresse la liste des
urgences et des défis qui attendent ce
nouveau gouvernement là encore le
pouvoir d'achat et la transition et
écologique mais aussi l'emploi et les
retraites le quotidien économique
pauline propose également un portrait de
pape ndiaye le nouveau ministre de
l'éducation venu de la gauche culturelle
est présenté comme la surprise de ce
nouvel exécutif pap ndiaye qui aura fort
à faire pour redonner de l'attrait au
métier d'enseignant selon libération qui
évoque le classe tête qui attend le
nouveau patron de l'éducation nationale
confrontée à la baisse inquiétante du
nombre de candidats au métier
d'enseignant l'arrivée de pape ndiaye
rue de grenelle aux côtés de ministres
venus de la droite qui laisse sceptique
le figaro pas très convaincu non plus
d'ailleurs par le maintien à la justice
d'eric dupond-moretti le journal
s'interroge sur cette répétition du en
même temps qu'il met sur le compte des
législatives à venir mais aussi sur le
caractère des manuels mag compte jusqu'à
la caricature je cite nouveau
gouvernement embarrassé on en parlait
dans le journal c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire par les révélations sur le
nouveau ministre des solidarités damien
abad visés par deux accusations de viol
accusations dont il se défend helen hill
après le site d'info mediapart calais
qui est à l'origine de ces révélations
la majorité présidentielle peine à
justifier cette nomination elisabeth
bornes disant ne pas avoir été au
courant du signalement effectué par
l'observatoire des violences sexistes et
sexuelles auprès de la république en
marche le 16 mai puis auprès du parquet
de paris le 20 mai c'est à dire le jour
même où est intervenue cette nomination
toujours beaucoup de réactions hélène
également ce matin à la décision de
quillan maps et de prolonger de trois
ans son contrat au psg alors que tout le
monde l'attendait au real hélène à la
fin de ce feuilleton haletant annonce
une révolution au sein du club parisien
dixit l'équipe qui parle d'un nouvelle
ère pour le psg qui a engagé une série
de chantiers majeurs autour de la star a
même ap
le jeune attaquant prend le soin de
remercier poliment le real madrid je
serai leur premier supporter pour la
finale de la ligue des champions
apparaît une déclaration for diplomatic
reprise ce matin par le quotidien
sportif espagnol marca des amis des
amabilités qui laisse fois non moi le
soir à 23 ans le prince de bondy est
devenu le roi de paris ce n'est pas 100
et on reste toujours très loin d'un
projet sportif basé sur le collectif
seule vraie recette du foot de haut
niveau mais ainsi va la vie quand
l'argent est plus fort que tout regrette
le quotidien belge et bim on ne sait qui
pas là-dessus hélène ont pour limiter
les importations de pétrole russe et
tenter de soulager le portefeuille des
consommateurs l'allemagne vient
d'adopter une loi instaurant le ticket
de tram mensuel à 9 euros pour les trois
mois d'été sur tous les réseaux et
jeunes du pays cette nouveauté pauline a
donné l'idée à une association anti
capitaliste d'inviter les vacanciers à
prendre d'assaut littéralement l'île de
sylt en une station balnéaire
ordinairement fréquenté par des
résidents fortunés des célébrités qui se
trouve au large de la côte allemand de
la mer du nord d'après the guardian
cette destination pour happy few comme
on dit en bon français pourrait devenir
le théâtre cet été d'une lutte des
classe à l'état pur avec d'un côté le
champagne de l'autre les canettes de
bière une destination exotique ans merci
beaucoup et elle